[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro d' europe et
donnons pas depuis le parlement européen
coronavirus oblige mais nous allons
échanger avec mes invités à distance sur
le déconfinement amorcé en europe 1
déconfinement vous allez loire en ordre
dispersé il pour en débattre j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir à distance karima
delli vous êtes eurodéputée française
vous siégez au sein du groupe les verts
je précise que vous présidez présidé la
commission transport et tourisme au
parlement européen et pour échanger avec
vous drague auspices la roue eurodéputés
romain renie où le groupe centriste au
parlement européen
bienvenue à tous les deux tout au long
de cette émission deux autres invités
deux citoyens européens
l'un depuis cambridge en angleterre
l'autre depuis hambourg en allemagne
et bien vous allez nous écouter et
intervenir pour nous faire part de vos
remarques et nous faire partager vos
quotidiens confiné où des confiné mais
avant d'entamer notre débat le point sur
la situation sanitaire en europe face à
la pandémie de coronavirus s'est résumé
pour vous par samia de fuir
elle seule l'europe comptabilise plus de
la moitié des décès liés aux covit 19 le
vieux continent étaient ce jour le plus
touché au monde mais la pandémie a
frappé inégalement son territoire
l'ouest est sans conteste le plus lourd
tribut à eux seuls quatre pays
concentrent plus des deux tiers des
décès le royaume-uni l'italie la france
et l'espagne comptabilisant ensemble
plus de cent dix mille morts ils ont
malgré tout commencé à lever
partiellement leur mesure de confinement
cette semaine quelques jours après
l'allemagne dont le taux de mortalité
est resté moins élevé que chez ses
voisins dans d'autres pays en revanche
cela fait déjà presque un mois que les
citoyens reprennent peu à peu leur
activité l'autriche a commencé son
déconfinement mi avril
comme la plupart des pays de l'est en
voyant la vitesse à laquelle le virus a
frappé l'ouest du continent
ils ont eu plus de temps pour prendre
des mesures drastiques avant que le coc
vite 19 ne les atteignent bulgarie
hongrie croatie à l'est tous les pays
compte pour l'instant moins de 1000
décès
c'est également le cas des pays du nord
de l'europe le danemark la norvège et la
finlande ont déclaré l'épidémie sous
contrôle seule la suède qui n'a pas
adopté de mesures de confinement déplore
plus de 3000 victimes
l'europe de l'ouest paye le plus lourd
tribut
l'europe centrale et l'europe de l'est
semble plus épargné plus préservé drague
auspices la roue comment vous expliquer
cette différence entre l'europe de
l'ouest et l'europe de l'est
tout d'abord je crois que c'est bon une
explication c'est lié au fait que
l'europe de l'est
les mesures de confinement étaient
drastiques et je crois que aider
vraiment une situation grave
les isolements qui a été très très
stigma liés ou une et à des rodéos gens
se déclarer roumanie ou bien d autres
pays de l'est de l'europe
bon on aidé c'est ça c'est clair qu'elle
est là délit en allemagne notamment le
taux de mortalité est resté moins élevé
alors on sait qu'il ya eu une vaste
campagne de dépistage est ce que cela
explique tout selon vous non cela
n'explique pas tout moi je crois que sur
tout ce qu' il faut surtout dire que la
santé c'est pas une compétence de
l'union européenne pourquoi on la
diversité d'un pays à l'autre parce
qu'il n'existe pas de coordination
européenne sur la santé publique et
prétendez nuit à montrer justement le
manque de cette coordination c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que cette pandémie s'est déclaré d'abord
en italie les italiens a appelé à l'aide
et malheureusement ces appels à l'aide
n'ont pas été entendus ce qui est train
puisque le chacun pour soi l'a remportée
par rapport à la solidarité que doivent
les états membres de l'union européenne
alors maintenant par rapport à
l'allemagne
l'allemagne elle a pris des mesures qui
sont beaucoup plus ambitieux que ce que
d'autres pays par exemple elle a sa
propre industrie notamment de
médicaments aux mêmes de masse qu'elle
ne dépend pas forcément d'un pays qu'on
appelle la chine
elle a également voulu mettre en
évidence le futur
pour sortir du déni il faut pas trop peu
de solutions elle se base sur trois
choses tout d'abord un avoir des masses
trn ou deux d'avoir des tests 3 d'abord
délits notamment dans les hôpitaux
et ces trois règles leur niveau de
l'allemagne où ont été respectés
contrairement à une période où notre
pays
dragos pis la roue est ce qu'il ya eu
des erreurs évidentes commises par
certains pays dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire
bon je veux commencer par dire que même
si on peut être d'accord que la
coordination européenne a démarré plus
lentement je crois qu'on peut pas dire
qu'on n'a pas d'écho du coordination est
l'effet mi avril la commission
européenne a publié la fille de routes
européennes la levée des mesures
d'isolement des grands navires us a
donné bon déclar é tait sur les
principaux rassemble des critères qui
doivent être prises et les mesures qui
doivent être prises sur le pont que vous
m'avez démontré
je crois que ni à diversité
en ce qui concerne aller le respect pour
rappeler les règles qui ont été imposées
on peut avoir sa bombe
une en fonction de la culture public de
respecter les règles bon les pays du sud
est les payeurs mais le plus importante
que dans d'autres c'est ça oui
exactement
exactement visuellement rapport qui
était pratiqué incident mais des pays
comme la cde bien que confrontée à
relativement monde qu'avant maintenant
tendance à cédantes stable mais est
lente mais je crois que c'est trop tôt
pour conclure quel était le meilleur
choix
dragos picardie vous nous avez parlé de
l'intervention quand même plus ou moins
coordonnée l'union européenne même si ça
a été en effet à très contestée ont
nakheel
assisté à lille et sochaux qu'on laisse
notamment l'achat global
cela a donné lieu en effet à des vols
entre états membres
karim abolissez sa l'union européenne en
il ya eu des gestes de solidarité on a
vu l'envoi de matériel médical même si
les images sont choquantes ou des pays
se battent tarmac chinois pour pouvoir
récupérer chacun en masque c'est quand
même dingue mais en europe il ya eu il
est vrai un peu tardivement par exemple
moi je le préside la commission
transports ya le transport et l'accueil
de malades français ou autres dans des
hôpitaux a demandé le rapatriement de
citoyens européens qui était le goût de
la terre hop on les a ramenés on a
commencé à s'organiser à part une
coordination sous l'égide de monsieur
breton sur le matériel médical a vu
aussi que l'europe se saisisse de la
question du vaccin donc donner des
chercheurs des médecins pour enclencher
cette dynamique de recherche
véritablement urgente maintenant la
véritable question que je crois qu'il
faut remercier l'ensemble des salariés
et au style du monde des transports sur
la logistique notamment le volet
alimentaire le bolide matériel etc
ils se sont véritablement coordonnées
même s'il ya eu des petits couacs
puisque la véritable problématique c'est
comme il n'y avait pas de coordination
nous voyez un pays à nous de fermer ses
frontières mais pour faire passer aux
marchands parfois c'est très dit il
karima delli pas de coordination pas de
coordination notamment concernant le
déconfinement amorcé en europe
dragos pis cela vous est ce que serait
pas été souhaitable c'est un peu plus de
coordination sur ce confinement
notamment pour être plus efficace
peut-être dans la lutte contre la
propagation du clavier alors je suis
d'accord
un effet que au niveau européen on peut
faire de plus mais je suis pas d'accord
qu'il vient à vue de coordination et on
peut pas nier les choses qui ont été
faites alors j'ai juste je ne veux pas
descendre là dans le fond
pas de coordination sur ce déconfinement
chaque pays a choisi de se dé confiné
selon son propre calendrier sa propre
stratégie la yaris ordination européenne
sur ce développement ne peut pas avoir
une coordination parfaite parce que la
pandémie de kobe 19 n'a pas éclaté
simultanément dans du lait payé aux
rebelles évolution n'a été pas
similaires alors de demander en démon
dans ce genre de condamnation peut faire
alors ça c'était pas realistic la levée
des restrictions a donc commencé à se
faire à différents moments et un de
différentes manières cependant bon et on
a maintenant une feuille de route on a
des règles bien sûr qu'au niveau
européen on va on ne parle pas de ce
genre de consignation parfaite
alors ça c'est très bien je comprendrais
pas accuser l union européenne pour ne
pas cordiner chose qui était lié au site
la ssla citoyens des minimes est-ce
qu'il ya tout de même un modèle de
déconfinement en europe je pense
peut-être à l'autriche où il ya peu de
morts déconfinement amorcée depuis la
mi-avril sans rebond pour le moment des
infections karima delli est ce que c'est
un modèle à suivre peut-être alors je
crois que il faut revenir sur il n'y a
pas de coordination au niveau européen
d'aidé confinement parce que il ya des
pays qui ont anticipé sur la cliente
c'est à dire qu'ils ont pris des mesures
de confinement beaucoup plus tôt ronde
sera organisée sur les masques etc et
ensuite on met un problème de
coordination quand même parce que si moi
je prends je ne sais pas le train qui va
des paris à bruxelles j'ai besoin de
savoir si l'érection cordonnier voiliers
qui dans les transports même si vous
êtes obligés d'avoir une obligation de
coordination partement vous auriez
souhaité plus de co2 coordination mais
ce qu il ya un modèle
de déconfinement en europe qui serait
que qui pourrait inspirer les autres
pays là en l'occurrence aujourd'hui
pour l'instant nous pouvons pas le dire
parce que tout le monde au doute
puis un retour d'une deuxième vague donc
moi je ne préfère pas dire aujourd'hui
qu'il y à des modèles mais couches de
sons et les secteurs et eulex passe
public non lorsqu'on regarde par exemple
les transporte partout et là c'est quand
même nouveau on voit que même en france
ou dans d'autres villes en europe
la bonne nouvelle c'est dire que une
mesure qui permet de de respecter les
scènes x et le vélo est mal à bruxelles
regarder la rue de la loi qui est la
plus polluée bild et les rues les plus
polluées d'europe
on voit bien que désormais la piste
cyclable va être totalement nouvelle
pour aménager tout ça on voit que des
bonnes pratiques un peu partout
maintenant il faudra une feuille de
route qu'ils soient claires je crois que
le temps du bilan il pas encore le cas
mais en tout cas il va falloir aussi
d'anticiper sur ces bonnes pratiques
partout en europe
encore en tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est que la plupart en tout cas de très
dangereuses et européens ont mis en
place ou sont en train de mettre en
place une application de tracking pour
suivre un petit peu l'état du vide mais
il y a dix ong des élus ou des citoyens
qui s'inquiètent en d'éventuelles
dérives et quitter ce citoyen de
résoudre à gospic cela vous comment
l'union européenne et le parlement
européen notamment peuvent-ils garantir
à la protection des données la
protection des libertés individuelles
notamment quelles sont les garanties que
vous pouvez donner au citoyen la
position de dénicher chez nous chez
renault europe ne sont que l'approché du
développement d'une application de
tracing bonté l'application doit être
coordonnée au niveau européen
premièrement avec des normes
obligatoires les solides garanties de
respect des droits fondamentaux qui sont
payés
en détails et en particulier liées aux
droits de la vie de reese et la
protection de données
bon cette application doivent être
conçus comme des outils complémentaires
est temporaire ça c'est très important
les sommes partis d'un plan d'isolement
bien qui comprend en outre des tests et
mesures sanitaires et des distensions
social isolement et l'a40 dean le
développement des traitements des
vaccins est assez rare est pas une une
solution qui va rester avec la
protection que vous avez karima delli
vous êtes d'accord en quelques en
quelques mots là c'est avec votre
collègue du groupe renault sur ses
applications de tracking je crois qu'il
faut aller plus loin
c'est à dire que là c'est une question
de liberté individus les écologistes
nous sommes très simple nous sommes
attachés à la vie privée et que pour
l'instant ce genre de dispositif n'a pas
encore montré son efficacité je rappelle
et ça c'est très important que l'union
européenne doit garantir notamment le
détournement possible des telles
applications celle via la première chose
c'est comment bagarre on m'a des
utilisateurs comment on va gérer
l'ensemble des données et comment on va
faire en sorte que ces données où il
reste un temps mais s'évapore ensuite et
tout ça pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
de garantie d'accor donc vous voulez
plus de garanties sur des applications
au niveau de l'union européenne
sanitaire mise aussi économique et
financière elle a de nombreuses
conséquences sur le terrain de la
solidarité européenne mais aussi en
matière d'état de droit ou encore de
libre circulation des personnes c'est un
sujet de samia deux chiffres
[Musique]
la pandémie de qu'ovide 19 donne des
ailes aux eurosceptiques
le 5 mai la justice allemande assaut
mené la banque centrale européenne de
justifier son programme de rachats de
dette publique la cour constitutionnelle
saisie par un groupe de citoyens
allemands jugent que ce programme lancé
en 2015 n'entre pas dans les compétences
de la bce et lui laisse trois mois pour
prouver le contraire
faute de quoi la banque centrale
allemande ne pourrait plus participer à
ce programme
la cour de justice européenne l'a
pourtant jugé légal
l'union européenne envisage donc de
porter plainte contre l'allemagne pour
non respect d'une décision de justice
européenne
pas question de laisser ce ouvrir une
brèche qui pourrait appeler d'autres
recours contre le plan à 750 milliards
d'euros annoncée par bruxelles pour
relancer l'économie européenne en 2020
autre règle d'or de l'europe mise à mal
par la pandémie
la libre circulation des citoyens dans
les pays membres
durant le confinant chaque pays a pris
ses propres mesures de fermeture ou de
contrôle des frontières la commission
appelle à une réouverture coordonnées
des frontières intérieures sans
discrimination de nationalité les
frontières extérieures de l'union reste
en revanche fermée pour tous les voyages
jugés non essentiels jusqu'au 15 jan en
europe la pandémie bouleverse également
l'organisation des élections
en pologne les citoyens étaient
initialement convoqué le 11 mai pour
choisir leur futur président l'actuel
chef de l'état andrée joda du parti
conservateur droit et justice est
candidat à sa réélection
mais après des préoccupations émises par
l'opposition et l'union européenne sur
les conditions d'organisation du vote le
parlement a décidé d'un report dimanche
les bureaux de vote sont donc restés
fermés une nouvelle date doit être
annoncé d'ici le 24 mai
je voudrais qu'on vienne sur un sujet
d'importance les frontières elles
restent fermés en europe et en dehors
pour le moment les déplacements sont
très limitées or on voit notamment pour
une nécessité économique de libre
circulation notamment en vue de la
saison estivale qu'il va falloir
peut-être penser autrement la commission
se penche sur ce sujet à caen à nouveau
la libre circulation des citoyens
européens dragos pis là où bon alors et
c'est clair que la commission européenne
travaille sur cela bon il ya une
stratégie qui est vraiment et rédigé par
la commission sur ce sujet je crois que
les recommandations qu'on va avoir
nous fournit une approche de trois
phases pour la réouverture des
frontières qui a rassemblé les états
membres avec des profits de risques
globaux similaire ça alors ça veut dire
que l'on peut avoir des mesures de
relaxer les conditions de confinement
une des cantines mans et une expansion
des couloirs verts qui ont eu jusqu'à
maintenant et je crois que ici l'agencé
européenne de lutte contre les maladies
cdc serait rédigée pour conserver une
liste des gens à faibles et circulation
de virus afin que les mesures de
quarantaine et clémentine général au
sein des chaînes de puissance être
supprimés eh ben on a les nouveautés
sont que les voyageurs pourront
consulter une carte interactive a établi
par le cdc qui ouvrira les derniers
contrôles font dire mesures et
conditions voyage ça ce sont des ddd
nouveautés qu'on a on a maintenant
karima link vous prédire la commission
transport et tourisme
il est nécessaire de rouvrir les
frontières en vue de la saison estivale
on voit que notamment pour les
professionnels du secteur le demande
sont très inquiets que la première chose
à dire ce que la commission va présenter
tout d'abord une carte européenne des
zones les plus touchées et des hommes
est moins touchée parce qu'on ne peut
pas
bouger là où ou des zones seraient à
risque et donc je pense qu'on peut
tabler d'ici un retour de principe on
aura d'ici quinze jours déjà une
sachant qu'ils aient déjà des états qui
disent on veut dire recevoir pendant des
touristes français mais les quinze
premiers jours dans le pays ce seront
des jours d'isolement
ensuite on a des pays qui vivent du
tourisme comme l'espagne qui elle
envisage de fermer sa frontière jusqu'en
octobre à défaut d'un accord européen et
d'un contrôle homogène dans les pays
deviennent et wis on a aussi le d'italie
qui évoque même pas de perspective de
l'ouverture dans son secteur qui ont
déjà fait le d'ailleurs de la saison à
supposer qu il appelle à faire un virage
mais de regarder le tourisme beaucoup
plus de proximité et régional dépend
plus des frontières en profite pour dire
un petit mot parce que lorsqu'on parle
des frontières nous ne devons jamais
oublier notamment les réfugiés qui eux
justement mérite complètement qu'on
s'intéresse à eux et qu'on les accueille
je crois qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
parler de cette question des frontières
et qu'on soit pas capable même en
d'acquérir les réfugiés qui ont aussi
besoin de nous dans cette période s'est
dit pour conclure ce débat et à l'heure
où la commission européenne présente son
plan pour une croissance verte
à quoi va ressembler l'europe d'après
coronavirus en une phrase drague
auspices l'art ou la relance économique
ça doit être une relance verte ça doit
être une réponse certes mais relance de
l'industrie et européens ont aussi une
rage de la transformation digitale que
nous souhaitons vers ans des petites et
moyennes entreprises et les entreprises
de famille et bon d'une autre côté une
relance de compétences pour le futur
pour le marché de travail qui est bon
liêu ou futur que nous attend alors s'il
y a il ya des choses qui sont claires
l'europe doit pas seulement réunir à ce
qui ce que
laure maltais était avant la crise honda
serait imaginé le futur on doit
renouveler le futur un heureux coup et
on va travailler ensemble pour cela ça
c'est une phase où bien de trois fois ci
et voilà sur cette question bien je vais
demander à nos deux citoyens européens
leur avis depuis conduite en angleterre
gregorc raid c'est depuis hambourg en
allemagne et nos chats faire et nos
chats faire est ce que vous partagez
cette vision de l'europe d'après une
vision en tout cas à verte écolo je
pense que maintenant c'était pas que
nous vivons c'est une rupture c'est une
chance une chance de repenser l'europe
de recenser beaucoup de beaucoup de
secteurs de la société et de ne pas
continuer comme on l'a fait avant
grégoire crif depuis cambridge est ce
que vous avez un mot à dire à nos
eurodéputés ou en commentaire à faire
sur ce que vous avez entendu durant
cette émission surtout leur souhaiter
bonne chance parce que j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses qui me plaisent et
c'est vrai beaucoup de gens ici même si
tu m'aimes avec le brésil et si on parle
de l'europe d'ici quelques mois beaucoup
de gens disent que c'est l'occasion
rêvée pour l'europe de se prouver une
fois de plus on parle de la crise
économique qui va frapper naturellement
ça va être l'occasion de prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent naturellement la
crise de la santé autour du virus
l'environnement aussi beaucoup de monde
ici dit que ce serait l'occasion rêvée
de faire des progrès de les gens se
montrent beaucoup plus au vélo ou
vous-même à la marche à pied ici donc si
on pouvait continuer comme ça se serait
pas fait très bien karima delli drago
qui cela roule je vais vous remercier
que je vais vous laisser vaquer
retournez à vos occupations et puis je
vous dis à bientôt j'espère au parlement
européen hors jeu pour tous au revoir je
poursuis désormais donc avec vous
grégoire crête
vous êtes français 1 mais vous vivez
depuis plus de 15 ans en angleterre vous
travaillez dans l'informatique et à vous
êtes encore dans un pays
confiné suite aux annonces de bruit
johnson il ya quelques jours comment se
passe du coup votre quotidien
confiné à cambridge en angleterre
écoutez très aiguë très égoïstement pour
moi ça va pas trop mal j'ai aucun
symptôme
j'arrive à travailler depuis la maison
on vit dans une ville qu'on risque à
part quelques petites et 44 et vertes
donc on arrive encore sorti il ya encore
de quoi manger dans le supermarché
donc ce n'était pas agréable d'être in
fine et naturellement elle met le
confinement est un peu plus léger que ce
qu'on a vu en france au début par
exemple c'est comparable mais on n'a pas
à assigner de formulaires à chaque fois
qu'on sorte par exemple savez notre
petit peu relâché en quoi est-ce que
vous avez la sensation que les
britanniques ont encore confiance ont
l'art exécutif alors qu'en europe le
royaume où est il le plus lourd tribut
en nombre de morts non non justement
c'est cette sainte était la grosse
surprise pour le gouvernement
on a vu la cote de popularité de boris
johnson le premier ministre remonter un
peu au début de la crise mais ça je
crois que c'est partout en europe avec
tous les chefs d'état mais il est
derniers sondages sont effrayants et je
crois que c'est au moins 75% de la
population ne font plus confiance au
gouvernement
et comment ça fait de moins en moins
confiance aux médias pour l'information
et qu'avez vous pensé du discours du
premier ministre britannique qui a
annoncé de nouvelles mesures de
déconfinement progressif très progressif
très sincèrement ce que je prends depuis
les bus et que c'est un petit rigolo qui
a maintenant perdu pied c'était facile
pour lui de faire des bons mots de serre
est lié quand la situation était à peu
près comme de 4 sur la vague du mexique
si vous voulez jouer la popularité là
dessus maintenant bas il est au pied du
mur et on lui demande des résultats et
c'est clair que malheureusement il n'est
pas compétent
c'est ça soit vivre des décisions prises
ou la stratégie de communication c'est
vraiment une catastrophe c'est pas une
surprise que l'europe soit maintenant le
pire pays en europe que le camp d'été à
présent sur le pire pays en europe au
niveau des morts on est presque on en
serait presque gré aux états unis d'être
encore pire que nous parce que c'est un
petit peu moins moins humiliant et d'un
homme chuck européennes ont été
humiliante parce qu'on a vu que
maintenant même l'italie a pitié de nous
c'est la grèce aussi c'est pour le
prestige pour l'amour propre des anglais
ça a été un coup vraiment énorme
on prend la direction d'hambourg en
allemagne où vous vous trouvez à nos
chers que je précise que vous êtes
directeur d'un lycée et vous nous avez
glee en préparant cette émission qu'il
est plus facile
de se confiner que de ceux des confiné
expliqué pourtant les épreuves du bac on
doit vous en allemagne et notamment dans
votre lycée oui absolument alors il
était assez facile au début de ce tir
est le fusible
c'est à dire d'arrêter tout comme ça
d'un moment à l'autre
tous étaient et à ben maintenant pour
redémarrer c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
par exemple les restaurants maintenance
et de hambourg parce que selon les
länder les régions c'est très différent
de les mesures de déconfinement mais au
jour d'aujourd'hui que les raisons
peuvent offrir
hambourg dont mais sous des conditions
de dedienne par exemple on ne peut on
peut servir seulement la moitié des des
tables ce qui ce qui est difficile pour
les pour les restaurateurs parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à combler leurs frais
dans les écoles c'est un peu pareil
maintenant on va offrir les écoles pour
toutes les classes même que des groupes
et des petits groupes de 15 de 15 élèves
ça veut dire que qu'il faut diviser la
classe en 2ème trois groupes
c'est à dire on fait découvre créer des
affiches aux mèches de ferme pédagogique
ça ne donne pas vraiment de sens et ça
c'est difficile ce que vous avez dit oui
on a on a organisé des examens du bac
oui ça mais on a en effet on l'a vu sur
vos photos que vous avez envoyées dans
des villages avec des bureaux d'un
espace et l'allemagne se dé confine
arnault dit est ce que vous craignez une
seconde vague alors que certains
nouveaux foyers de contamination
apparaissent en allemagne dans certains
propos
là contrairement à la majorité des gens
en allemagne ce type à experts on va
maintenant beaucoup d'experts qui est ce
qu'ils cherchent
les microphones moi je ne suis pas je ne
sais pas de dire aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
beaucoup peur mais aujourd'hui j'ai lu
un article du roomba correnti tout notre
institut de de santé qui dit que si on
reste dans des déserts responsable or on
peut peut-être même éviter une seconde
vague mais il peut pas le dire très bien
on vous compter sur la responsabilité
individuelle de chacun ce seront les
mots de la fin merci beaucoup à tous les
deux pour vos témoignages c'est la fin
de cette émission vous pouvez la voir et
la revoir sur notre site publicsenat.fr
mais également sur l'antenne de la rtbf
et on se quitte sur ces images le
concert à l'occasion de la journée des
70 ans de l'union européenne un
anniversaire un petit peu particulier
dans une europe encore confiné à très
vite pour de nouvelles aventures sur
opel
[Musique]